tutti quanti vi diciamo sempre che è
difficile fare previsioni meteorologiche
oltre ai tre quattro giorni diffidare di
chi si avventura più in là
come è possibile pensare di fare
previsioni per i prossimi vent'anni
la risposta a questa domanda è
tecnicamente un po complessa ma cercherò
di rendere il più semplice possibile
dobbiamo distinguere fra il meteo cioè
le caratteristiche dell'atmosfera su
tempi brevi
quando vogliamo sapere quando comincia a
piovere quando finisce di piovere
quanto sarà l'intensità del vento quando
si spostano nei nubi e quindi abbiamo
risposto bisogno di risposte su tempi
veloci e sulla variabilità di ora in ora
dello stato dell'atmosfera
ma quando parliamo di clima ci riferiamo
ha delle caratteristiche che vanno oltre
la singola giornata oltre la singola
settimana parliamo di valori medi del
mese di novembre valori medi della
stagione estiva e quindi ci
accontentiamo di avere le
caratteristiche di massima di queste
variabili
se ci accontentiamo di avere queste
caratteristiche allora possiamo spingere
i nostri modelli ben oltre i 3 4 giorni
e quindi avventurarci grazie alle
informazioni che abbiamo sulle
caratteristiche del nostro pianeta anche
al 2020 ma prima di dire che cosa
succederà fra vent'anni
cerchiamo di capire dove siamo adesso
cosa è successo fino ad ora il grafico
che vedete le mie spalle è una sintesi
di tanti studi cerchiamo di essere
concisi e vi fa vedere sostanzialmente
due informazioni una informazione sono
le barrette colorate ciascuna di quelle
barrette corrisponde al valore della
temperatura media annua globale cosa
vuol dire è il valore medio su tutta la
superficie terrestre ottenuto da
tantissime misure immediato su un intero
anno
parliamo di clima quindi è appropriato
riferirci a un intero anno perché sono
colorate di colore rosso rappresenta le
differenze di temperatura rispetto alla
media di un intero secolo il xxi secolo
quindi se in quell'anno la temperatura è
stata più alta della media del secolo la
barretta sarà rossa se è stata più bassa
sarà blu vedete che il grafico comincia
dal 1880 cosa significa significa che da
1880 ad oggi ai giorni nostri
le anomalie cioè le differenze
inizialmente erano più blu che mano a
mano che ci si è spostati verso i doni
nostri sono diventate sempre più
frequentemente rosse che sempre più
grande e quindi è abbastanza chiaro che
la temperatura media annua globale del
pianeta sta aumentando
accanto a questo dato vedete anche una
curva nera cosa rappresenta quella curva
nera va letta sull'asse di destra e
rappresenta la concentrazione di
anidride carbonica nell'atmosfera del
nostro pianeta
vedete anche lì al di là dei valori che
il trend è continuamente in aumento la
tendenza ha avuto anzi un'accelerazione
attorno agli anni ottanta vedete che la
curva subito un'impennata
qualcuno di voi si domanderà ma perché
cominciamo nel 1880 che cosa sappiamo di
quel che è accaduto prima
la risposta è questa fino a metà
dell'ottocento le osservazioni dirette
mediante strumentazione della
temperatura non erano moltissime
addirittura anche le misure dirette di
co2 erano pochissime questo non
significa che non sappiamo cosa sia
accaduto prima
lo possiamo ottenere in maniera
indiretta analizzando gli anelli di
accrescimento degli alberi
analizzando le carote di ghiaccio che
andiamo a scavare nel ghiacciaio in
antartide
analizzando le stalagmiti delle rocce
quindi da molti altri componenti del
sistema pianeta riusciamo a ricavare
informazioni sull'andamento della
temperatura e della co2 nel nostro
pianeta
quello che abbiamo concluso è che nelle
ultime centinaia di migliaia di anni
la temperatura ha oscillato moltissimo
le concentrazioni di co2 hanno variato
moltissimo ma mai si sono raggiunti
valori come quelli raggiunti negli
ultimi 20 30 anni
stiamo esplorando un ambito del nostro
clima che la terra non ha mai vissuto e
di conseguenza facciamo fatica a capire
in che territorio inesplorato ci stiamo
avventurando stiamo facendo un
esplorazione in situazioni che il nostro
pianeta non ha mai vissuto
ma perché è così importante occuparci
dell'anidride carbonica
perché il carbonio d'altra parte una
delle di carbonica co2 è un composto del
carbonio dell'ossigeno è così importante
e così importante perché la co2
rappresenta uno dei più importanti gas
serra cioè quei gas che rende la nostra
atmosfera capace di assorbire radiazione
infrarossa emessa dal suolo assorbendo
più radiazione la stessa atmosfera si
scalda ed emette a sua volta verso il
suolo quindi tutto il sistema pianeta
aumenta la propria temperatura di
conseguenza maggiore è il contenuto di
co2 in atmosfera maggiori saranno le
temperature questo spiega perché i due
grafici andavano d'accordo più co2 più
temperatura ma quali sono i fattori che
controllano la concentrazione di co2
nell'atmosfera
noi abbiamo imparato a scuola che la
fotosintesi clorofilliana è un processo
controllato dai vegetali che producono
al clorofilla che assimila co2
dall'atmosfera la fissa come carbonio
nelle piante nelle biomasse e libera
ossigeno
questo è un processo importantissimo che
ha consentito al nostro pianeta della
sua storia di ridurre di molto la
concentrazione iniziale di co2
stabilizzarla ai valori che
caratterizzava non era pre industriale e
regolare le temperature del pianeta in
maniera tale da renderlo vivibile per i
vegetali e per noi
tra l'altro la fotosintesi produce anche
ossigeno che regola la concentrazione di
ozono e quindi rende il nostro ambiente
meno inospitale per che filtra la
radiazione ultravioletta quindi la
vegetazione è un elemento
importantissimo per controllare la co2
atmosferica vedete infatti che nel
diagramma le mie spalle ci sono alcune
frecce che rappresentano gli scambi di
co2 fra la vegetazione il suolo
l'atmosfera l'oceano tutte le componenti
del pianeta scambiano tra loro carbonio
in diverse maniere vedete diverse
freccette che vanno verso l'alto o verso
il basso ma con colori molto diversi
il colore rossiccio rappresenta fenomeni
relativamente veloci veloci nei tempi
del clima dell'ordine di un anno come il
ciclo annuale noi assistiamo di anno in
anno alle piante che crescono le vediamo
perché assimilando carbonio cresce il
fusto crescono i rami poi ci sono
processi relativamente più lenti il
colore verde il giallo
giallo arancione sono processi
dell'ordine di 1 10 anni processi più
lenti ancora quelli verdini e poi
processi molto lenti tra i processi
molto lenti verde scuro ci sono gli
scambi tra atmosfera e oceano
cosa c'entra l'oceano l'oceano è un
grande serbatoio non solo di acqua ma
anche di carbonio perché non li divide
carbonica diffonde nell'acqua
dell'oceano anzi un eccesso di anidride
carbonica rende l'oceano un po più acido
e quindi e pericolose per i viventi ma
gli organismi viventi sono in grado di
assimilare questo carbonio sia le alghe
che come vegetali fanno fotosintesi sia
altri animaletti che usano il carbonio
per fare mediante i carbonati i gusci le
conchiglie gli scheletri e quindi
riescono a rimuovere carbonio dall
oceano assimilarlo e quando il loro
ciclo di vita si è concluso se
diventarlo sul fondo ma questo è un
processo molto lento
gli oceani sono dei serbatoi enormi in
grado di regolare il contenuto di co2 in
atmosfera ma lavorano su scale
lentissime viceversa vedete una freccia
verso l'alto sopra il fumo di quelle
ciminiere che ci ricorda che noi stiamo
come uomini immettendo in atmosfera
anidride carbonica quando bruciano
combustibili fossili
cosa sono i combustibili fossili sono
biomasse che si erano formate mediante
la fotosintesi e anziché essere
restituite come co2 in atmosfera
bruciando subito o decomponendosi sono
state archiviate nel sottosuolo
grandi forme di biomasse vegetali
animali sono rimaste per millenni
sepolte non ossidate sotto il suolo
quando abbiamo imparato a tirarle fuori
e a utilizzarle per la combustione per
l'industria per i trasporti per mille
altre applicazioni
abbiamo cominciato uno sviluppo
incontrollato che ha portato ad
aumentare continuamente il fabbisogno di
questa combustione di conseguenza si
stima che oggi ai tassi attuali
immettiamo co2 in atmosfera bruciando
quel carbonio quanto ne è servito alla
fotosintesi per produrlo in mille anni
mille anni di fotosintesi vengono
restituiti in un anno di applicazione
industriale quindi capite già qua della
strada se vogliamo controllare il
terreno in cui ci stiamo muovendo con il
nostro clima
dobbiamo mettere mano alle emissioni di
co2 e il relatore che mi ha preceduto la
detto molto chiaramente il panel
intergovernativo per i cambiamenti
climatici che è l'organismo di cui
l'organizzazione delle nazioni unite si
è dotata per capire che cosa sta
succedendo ha dato un'indicazione
abbastanza chiara il diagramma che
vedete la vostra sinistra rappresenta le
emissioni di co2 di tutto il pianeta
vedete che è continuamente in aumento ma
prevede che virtuosamente dal 2020
mediante un accordo planetario ci si
metta d'accordo per ridurre queste
emissioni con due possibili scenari
ridurla entro 20 anni al 2040 aver
azzerato il surplus di emissioni o al
più tardi al 2050 5
quale sarà la conseguenza questo
diagramma ci fa vedere dove siamo
arrivati fino ad oggi il puntino rosso
vedete che la curva rossa che
rappresenta la media climatologica delle
fluttuazioni di temperatura continua a
salire sopra quella ci sono tutte le
oscillazioni vedete quella curva
seghettata ci fa vedere che il meteo
continua a variare ma l'andamento medio
è continuamente in aumento se non
facciamo niente se business e si usa
come si dice la tendenza sarà la curva
tratteggiata alla freccia ci fa vedere
un aumento incontrollato un aumento
incontrollato che ripeto ci fa andare
verso una regione un livello dell'ordine
di 1.5 gradi sopra il valore pre
industriale che rappresenta l'ambito
oltre il quale non sappiamo che cosa può
succedere
non è soltanto questione della
temperatura può sembrare poco 1.5 gradi
ma 1.5 gradi vuol dire fusione dei
ghiacci innalzamento dei livelli del
mare vuol dire desertificazione vuol
dire stress per noi che viviamo in città
sempre più calde e tutta una serie di
conseguenze che ripeto non sappiamo
ancora valutare quanti e quali saranno
cosa succede se proviamo a ridurre le
nostre emissioni come ci ha suggerito
dai pc si beh il diagramma di destra con
gli opportuni margini di incertezza
vedete delle bande non delle curve ci
dice che questo è
una ricetta riduzione entro il 2040 2050
5 che ci consente di rimanere entro un
grado e mezzo e eventualmente cominciare
a ridiscendere tempi molto lunghi perché
come abbiamo visto l'assimilazione
avviene per tempi lunghissimi ma almeno
non ci avventuriamo in situazioni che
non sappiamo quale esito sarà daranno
come si fa ad ottenere questo con
accordi internazionali è importante
l'azione individuale è importante
l'azione collettiva
la nuova zelanda notizia di questi
giorni ha adottato un piano che la
porterà a dar ridurre le emissioni a
zero emissioni nette al 2050
questo è un paese virtuoso si può fare
occorre rivedere naturalmente il nostro
modo di produrre il nostro modo di
vivere
ma si può fare quindi che qui ma farà
nel 2039 dipende da noi dipende dalle
nostre scelte
grazie
[Applauso]